robbie ray facing the red sox for the
third time in his last four starts
making his 22nd start of the season
fourth against the red sox for this
season
got him came right back with the heater
and he blows away rafael devers to end
the top half of the first
good start for robbie ray
nick pavetta who's making like robbie
ray
his third start in the last four games
against the blue jays
and that's a great pitch 97
right there at the bottom of the zone to
strike him out
right past him struck him out nice start
for nick pavetta one two three they go
the 2-2 to renfro swinging a miss
he got him with a slider
[Applause]
back-to-back strikeouts for robbie ray
and one down
breaking ball hit hard lined right to
the shortstop bow beshet makes a nice
grab to his left
bobby ray three up three down into
second
seventh pitch of the at-bat on the way
fastball 97.
that's three consecutive strikeouts for
the right-hander
nick pavetta doing a great job going up
in the zone using both sides of the dish
this is popped up again simpion backing
into the outfield
he makes the catch
one down
[Applause]
the right field line makes a nice
over-the-shoulder catch
our use is retired two away robbie ray
one ball
two strikes
threw it again little dribbler toward
third espionage
what a play
oh my
with two strikes he's playing deep at
third a little roller up the line and
espinal saves a hit for robbie ray
[Music]
cut on and missed down he goes strike
three
fourth k in the book for pavetta
goes after that one it's a high
pop-up
renfro will put that away two down
[Music]
to center field hernandez right there
barely had to move
and the side is retired just like that
3-0 swinging away as ball is hit deep to
right fear that ball is caught by oscar
what a long run he had
he made up his mind he was going to
catch it right up against the fence in
right field verdigo given the green
light hit a fly ball deep to right but
it's the first out of the top of the
fourth
tie oscar
knew that ball wasn't going to leave the
ball parked i was watching him race
after that it took a good route he
wanted to make sure where the wall was
but he knew that ball wasn't leaving
he knew if he could get to it he could
make it out and robbie ray says hmm
raise a hand oh and chew
swung on and miss that slider against
bogart's third strikeout for robbie ray
two down
basketball hit on the ground but gurion
is there he'll go to the back robbie ray
another three up three down inning we go
to the bottom of the fourth it's a
scoreless game
back to the heat
devers
gets him
one away in the fourth
going after that one and a pop-up a
little collision there plucky went right
into the hitter but recovers to make the
play
two down
and vladimir without a hit so far
in the series
after an over last night
96 miles an hour popped it up
and nick pavetta through four innings
has been perfect here in toronto
and comes back with a slider to get this
strikeout renfro strikes out a second
time at good breaking ball from robbie
ray
toward the hole and through for a base
hit
so the red sox have their first knock
and it's the first one for either team
today a one out single in the fifth
inning
ground ball to third esplanade to second
for one back to first double play
santiago espinal really took his time he
knew he had some time with the dh
vasquez they turn an inning ending
double play
[Music]
bechet with a high long fly renfro back
to the track to make the catch
and bushette flies out on the first
pitch here in the bottom of the fifth
roped into left but it hangs up and a
catch made by verdugo
on a sinking line drive shaking his head
but he caught it
before it got to the turf and there are
two down
line drive there's a base hit
kk hernandez gets over to cut it off as
dickerson took a big turnaround first
but hustles back to the bag a first hit
first base runner for the blue jays
comes with two outs here in the fifth
round base hit into left field dalbeck
advancing up to second and stopping
there
so the red sox have two men on base for
the first time today against robbie ray
another 2-2 pitch
slider called strike three
robbie ray caught the inside corner [ __ ]
hernandez didn't like the call
[Applause]
fastball hit on the ground second for
one back to first not in time curiel
made a terrific catch did he touch first
base i was watching verdugo right here
after he went through buck he ran back
and touched the base and i'm like is
guriel on the base and he ended up being
on the base he should be out at first
base they need to take a look at this
one
and they are
and here's we got the answer coming
right now
oh no
pops it up curiel down the right field
line in the foul ground makes the catch
and robbie roy gets out of it
he strands a pair of base runners
mixing it up well on the sixth inning
he's been using all his pitches
throughout this game very effectively
beauty in there to strike him out
right to the feet of debra's and in
plenty of time to get the force play
nothing comes with a walk still nothing
nothing
one and two
paul strike three
romano made an adjustment with his
slider and he strikes out policy
here at rogers center there's no score
marcus simeon beau buchette and the
oscar hernandez now against matt barnes
remember the blue jays have just one hit
simeon goes out to the first pitch high
and deep to left get up get out of here
and down game winner for marcus simeon
his first career walk-off home run